من اسطنبول الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجي
العقيد الركن حاتم كريم الفلاحي العقيد
الفلاحي قراءه وفهم عسكري
لمسار العمليات ومسار المعارك خلال ال 24
ساعه
الماضيه نعم تحيه لكم ومشاهدي قناه
الجزيره نعم حقيقه بدات المعارك تستعر مره
اخرى في القطاع الشمال وكذلك في القطاع
الجنوبي في القاطع الشمالي حقيقه من غزه
عادت المعارك مره اخرى الى منطقه جنوب غرب
مدينه غزه وهذه
المنطقه يعني منذ البدايه كانت فيها
العمليات ولا تزال يعني مستعره بشكل كبير
جدا علما بان القوات الصهيونيه خففت
تواجدها في هذه المنطقه خلال الفتره
الماضيه وقالت بانها انتقلت الى المرحله
الثالثه من العمليات ولكن مع هذا لازالت
الفرقه 162 تدير العمليات العسكريه بلوائي
اللواء 401 وهو لواء مدرع ويتالف من اربعه
كتائب الكتيبه التاسعه والكتيبه 46
والكتيبه 52 بالاضافه الى كتيبه الهندسه
601 اما اللواء الاخر فهو لواء مشات وهو
لواء ناحال و يتكون ايضا من اربعه كتائب
الكتيبه 50 الكتيبه 931 932
و934 اللي تعتبر كتيبه الدوريه وهذا يعني
بانه لازالت تتواجد هناك قوات عسكريه في
هذه المنطقه الامر الذي جعل هذه القوات
تحاول الوصول الى بعض المناطق التي تتواجد
فيها فصائل المقاومه فا احتدمت المعارك
بشكل كبير جدا في منطقه الصناعه في منطقه
حي الجامعات في تلك عن مناطق الشمال
العقيد
الفلاحي نعم نعم نعم عن مناطق الشمال
سياتي الى الجنوب بعدين انت طلبتوا قراءه
عسكريه فانا افصل الامر يعني فلذلك
بدات معارك تستعر في هذه المنطقه الان
بشكل كبير جدا اما في المنطقه الجنوبيه
فيبدو بان المعارك تركزت في منطقتين
المنطقه الاولى هي منطقه حي الامل الذي
يقاتل فيها اللواء 35 مظليين وهذا اللواء
يتكون من ثلاثه كتائب الكتيبه 101 الكتيبه
202 والكتيبه 890 بالاضافه الى كتيبه
الدوريه واللواء الاخر هو لواء جفعاتي
وهذا اللواء هو من الفرقه 162 ويقاتل الان
في منطقه جنوب خان يونس ويبدو انه يحاول
التوغل الى وسط البلد او الى عمق مدينه
خان يونس من هذه المنطقه الامر الذي جعله
يصطدم بفصائل المقاومه التي تتواجد في هذه
المنطقه الامر بشكل عام ادى الى احتدام
المعارك ما بين الطرفين وراينا بالامس
بانه كانت هناك خسائر كبيره يعني عندما
اعلنت كتائب القسام تدمير ما يقارب 43
اليه وتنفيذ 17 عمليه تعرضيه اضاف الى ذلك
كان هناك عمليات قنص وكانت هناك عمليه
تدمير لان انفاق من خلال مصائد المغفلين
بتفخيخ هذه الانفاق وجعل القوات
الاسرائيليه تدخل الى هذه المنطقه ثم
القيام بتفجير هذه الانفاق على القوات
المتقدمه بالاضافه الى الاشتباكات
المباشره والازدحام المباشر الذي ادى الى
مقتل وجرح ما يقارب 15 جندي من القوات
الصهيونيه جميع هذه الفعاليات هي تجري في
القاطع الجنوبي ويقول الجيش الصهيوني بانه
يحتاج الى اسبوعين لغرض انتهاء العمليات
الكبرى في هذه المنطقه ولكن على هذه
العمليات اعتقد بانه هذا الوقت الذي حدده
لن يكون دقيق لانه يبدو بان التقديرات
الصهيونيه للعمليات العسكريه غير دقيقه
سواء كانت في الشمال اوعود الى دقه
العمليات نعود الى دقه العمليات ولكن
نتوقف مع هذا الخبر العاجل سري القدس تقول
قصفنا بقذائف الهون تمركز لجنود واليه
العدو في محور التقدم جنوب غرب خان يونس
ايضا نقلا عن مراسل الجزيره فان هناك
اشتباكات بالاسلحه الرشاشه الثقيله في
جنوب
مدينه غزه وهنا اعود اليك العقيد الفلاحي
عن عوده المعارك الى مدينه غزه والى شمال
القطاع وهي المناطق التي تحدث جيش
الاحتلال بانه انهى المعارك فيها بعد اكثر
من
121 يوم على العدوان الاسرائيلي على غزه
دلالات ذلك في
تقديرك نعم بدايه دعيني اقول بانه القاطع
الشمالي لم تنتهي فيه المعارك بل استمرت
المعارك وان خفت وتيرتها في الفتره
الماضيه ولكن يبدو بانها عادت الى الاحداث
مجددا وهذا يعطي دلاله واضحه على ان
التقديرات بالنسبه لقاده الجيش الصهيوني
بان هذه المنطقه التي تم التوغل فيها خلال
المرحله الاولى من العمليات لم تاتي
بنتائج حقيقيه وبالتالي هم يعودون الان
الى العمليات العسكريه مره اخرى وقد يتطلب
هذا زياده عدد القطعات العسكريه بالنسبه
للجيش الصهيوني خصوصا خصوص اذا اذا استمرت
هذه المعارك واذا ما اثقلت هذه القطعات
بالكثير من الخسائر خصوصا في المنطقه
الجنوبيه والجنوبيه الغربيه لمدينه غزه
لانه في الفتره الماضيه تم سحب الكثير من
القطعات في هذه من هذه المنطقه واخرها كان
اللواء الخامس مشات وبالتالي الان عادت
هذه المعارك مره اخرى لتستعرض علما بان
هناك روايه للجيش الصهيوني يقول فيها
بانه حاولت قسم من القطعات ان تتقدم الى
بعض المناطق لغرض التفتيش ولكن حاولت
فصائل المقاومه تعطيل عمل القطعات
العسكريه الامر الذي جعل المعارك تكون
عنيفه في هذه المنطقه ما بين الطرفين
فلذلك المنطقه الشماليه لم تنتهي فيها
المعارك بشكل كامل وانما استمرت المعارك
في الفتره الماضيه بعد ان خفت وتيرتها وها
هي تعود مره ثانيه الى واجهه الاحداث شكرا
جزيلا لك من اسطنبول الخبير العسكري
والاستراتيجي العقيد الركن حاتم كريم
الفلاحي